Can employers make vaccines mandatory?
You know, what's possible will really depend on what country you're in.
Some countries like Canada, it's certainly quite hard.
In Britain, if you are hiring new staff, then, certainly, that does appear to be the case.
I know that employers here do want to do this for existing staff...
...and I think what we will see in Britain and in other countries...
...is that this will get tested legally as employers bring this in.
And in the United States,...
...state governments and private employers can definitely mandate vaccines.
There are three exceptions that tend to come into play.
There's personal beliefs, religion, as well as medical exceptions.
And in some states, like California and New York,...
...they don't even actually allow for a religious exemption...
...or a personal belief exemption.
So, it's actually quite surprising when you dig in.
Do you think governments will ever make COVID vaccines mandatory?
Well, we know that they have in Saudi Arabia.
We know that the Moscow government...
...has rolled out a mandatory vaccination program for service sector workers.
So, I think it's clear that some governments will do this.
It is not constitutional for the federal government...
...to require all US citizens to get a vaccine.
What would be more likely to happen...
...is that state governments require it to varying degrees.